[Music]
as the new year begins we're taking you
behind the scenes for a look at our
extensive data and statistics we have
analyzed in detail how you reacted to
various releases in 2022 in three
categories and which film is the
community's favorite above all we wanted
to know which movies kept you engaged
the most that's why we didn't just focus
on the highest number of views but where
there were the most interactions per
viewer where were you the most eager to
discuss which videos did you immediately
have to share with your friends and what
got your likes our rankings are based on
all the videos that were uploaded for a
film and we have now compiled the
results for you here in this video
in our first category we analyzed which
movies were the most discussed among you
for this purpose we calculated the ratio
between views and comments and thus
obtained a list of the films that
received the most comments per viewer
the film drama the woman King won this
category by far many people were
particularly upset by the fact that the
film lacks any reference to actual
historical facts other comments however
found the woman King entertaining and
are unable to understand the criticism
the silver medal is awarded to two
movies with the same ratings Rob
Zombie's horror comedy the monsters and
the rom-com Bros the Monsters has
gathered some comments mainly due to its
trash Factor many comparing it either to
a 90s Disney production or an amateur
video in Bros you got tired of the
boring story While others thought the
trailer was funny following close behind
is the historical film emancipation the
comments under these videos are less
about the movie itself as they are
filled with jokes about Wilson freak out
at the Oscars which is without a doubt a
slap in the face for those in charge of
the film fifth place was secured by
Disney's remake of Pinocchio the Remake
was eagerly awaited but the mood was
very mixed not everyone thinks it's a
good thing that one animated classic
after another gets a live action
adaptation so even children's and family
films are by no means immune to Wild
discussions
let's move on to the second category and
reveal which film you have shared the
most with your family and friends for
this purpose we calculated the views of
all videos of the respective films from
2022 with the number of shares this
revealed which movies were shared the
most per viewer reached the most popular
share is Beavis and Butthead do the
universe the two cult characters from
the 90s are returning to the big screen
after many years and this has caused you
to happily share a full 6.5 percent of
you shared the trailer we wonder how
many Millennials there were second place
goes to the action comedy violent night
which 5.3 percent of you shared
according to the comments the film was
very well received with David Harbor in
the lead role causing many laughs the
bronze medal goes to everything
everywhere all at once the science
fiction film scored with its
unpredictable plot and is even
considered by some to be one of the best
films of 2022 so it's not surprising
that just under 4.7 percent of viewers
shared it with their friends the woman
King and smile ranked close behind with
only a small gap between them the woman
King already holds first place among the
most controversial movies which is why
we are undoubtedly talking about one of
the most discussed movies of 2022. 4.3
percent of you at least couldn't keep
the trailers from your friends the
horror film smile then took fifth place
also with 4.3 shares per view it quickly
became the most successful horror film
since the beginning of the pandemic and
also received positive reviews many of
you probably did not want to deal with
the creepy trailer alone which is why it
was actively shared last but not least
we arrive at the Supreme discipline the
movies that you liked best and expressed
that by giving them a thumbs up we use
the number of likes per viewer on all
published videos of the films from 2022
as the basis for our data the Japanese
animated film Belle has received the
most thumbs up from you and is Therefore
your favorite film of 2022 the emotional
story which is based on Beauty and the
Beast was obviously well received by you
close second place goes to the romantic
comedy my fake boyfriend this matches
the movie reviews which were likewise
rather positive in third place was the
Bob's Burgers movie the movie spin-off
of the popular animated series although
it failed to achieve major success at
the box office the movie went down well
with critics and fans the choice between
fourth and fifth place was once again a
close call for the most liked movies of
2022 by a narrow lead the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special took the
fourth spot however the videos of
Uncharted with Tom Holland came in just
after and therefore end up in fifth
place
what are some of your favorites for 2022
and where do they match up with our
findings please leave us a comment if
you liked our analysis a small service
note to finish off we also post the
dislikes under many of our videos as a
comment so you can always get a
realistic and accurate picture of how
well a video is really received
[Music]
foreign
[Music]